You can access all of your content in Fab from right within the editor by pressing either
the Fab button that's located next to the Add button and the Content Browser, or by
clicking the Add button and then from Get Content Clicking Fab.
No matter which method you choose, it will open up the Fab browser, which will then allow
you to browse, download, and purchase content for any of your projects.
Let's go ahead and take a look at how that works now.
So again, we can access this two different ways.
From our Content Browser, we can click on Add and Fab, or we can click on Fab right here.
Once we do that, Fab will open up and I've already been logged in, so that's why you'll
see some things populate here for me, but if you haven't logged in, you will need to
log in before you can download items from your library.
And let's just click on these rocks right here and we'll go Add to my project right
there and we will see in our Megascans here, give it just a moment.
And there we go.
There is our rock.
Let me just move this over and here we go.
So there we go.
There is our asset right from Fab that we can use and then pull right into our project
should we want to use that particular asset.
So again, remember Fab can be accessed from two locations by clicking the Fab icon right
here or by going to Add and clicking on Fab from right here.
Once the Fab browser is open, you are then able to browse and purchase, download and
add to your project any content that you may desire.